you know I like to invite our president
president Trump to the Masjid why it's
red down the street from your beautiful
home red down the road he's down the
road he's right down the road more and
more people are there understanding
Islam because you keep us constantly on
your mind and your thoughts on the TV
they see you was called the hijab they
say she's subjugated she's oppressed
what do you say to that when you hear
that wearing this a [ __ ] I'm a superstar
when I don't wear my hijab I feel like
I'm nothing why because I'm not doing
for the people I'm doing it because I
fear my Lord and I mean you look at the
history and the great women of the world
who wore hijab you know we started with
our mother Mary then we started with
look at mother Teresa she was one of the
most beloved women in the world she wore
her [ __ ] look at our beloved nuns look at
them so you came to visit the Muslims
here how's your experience been and
why'd you come now that's how you make
America great again
[Music]
guys how you doing I'm here with some
special guests I'm gonna start off with
imam che Bulow and sister Linda Miki and
she wants to send Trump a message she
wants to get him over here to the Masjid
and Daytona she's worked for the city
for over 38 years and just successfully
retired here of our guest said I'll make
you guys how you doing very very nice to
meet everyone there I hope and invite
you to our mustard we have a mumble out
here who's got his master's degree in
Islam we do a lot of community events
and as a city employee I was the only
Muslim with over 30 well I would say 30
employees there's over 1,000 to the
employees I wore my hijab and they
treated me with respect
I am the Imam Bilal we do a lot of
outreach programs community outreach
program bringing people to Islam
inviting them to the mosque you know I
like to invite our president president
Trump to the Masjid why because we like
for him to be amongst the Muslim get to
know us ask us questions about our
religion see how we are brothers and
sisters when he come to this mustard he
will find black Muslims white Muslim
Puerto Rican Muslims Muslims from all
over the world and we would read him and
we would like for him to know that we
would be very honored if he visit our
Masjid we would feed him the best food
you can imagine but most important we
want him to come and to get to know the
Muslim community here in Daytona Beach
Imam Bulow
he goes out to the churches the jura
synagogues they welcome us with this
league we had a tragedy where our Jewish
community brothers and sisters were
murdered Imam Bilal went to the Jewish
community they embraced him we talked
with these people the Muslims came we
were one OMA we were one community that
day the Jewish community with us and we
were with them and this is what we want
our president to see that the
world is united and we thank our
president for bringing Muslim culture
and religion into the forefront Thank
You president I personally would like to
thank you because more and more people
they know about Islam more and more
people are there understanding Islam
because you keep us constantly on your
mind and your thoughts on the TV come to
Daytona Beach see how we integrate with
one another see how the people is one
community brothers and sisters from all
over the world and mr. Trump
president Trump please come in April to
see us Imam Bilal would like to extend
that invitation father and as you see we
will have our Jewish community here we
will have our atheist community here we
will have our Catholic community here
Palestine baptism they all are welcome
to the mustard we open our doors and
April we have a huge program where over
a thousand non-muslims come to our
mustard and get to know us better also
and our mustard one of the things that
Imam Bilal support 100% we have a day
camp and a summer camp for Muslims and
non Muslim free free we stay and keep
your tourism from 7:30 a.m. until 6
o'clock when school is out we call a day
camp we invite the non-muslim children
we give them coats we give them food to
give them whatever they need we are one
umma one community and we look forward
president to see you come here so you
can be part of this Ummah you guys get
to see the optimism Muslim community I
remember Muslims are those just like
Jesus Abraham and all the other prophets
those who have submitted to the will of
the creator and now we have the Imam
here of the community here in Daytona
right you approve this message
I approve this message hundred percent
you know every year we have we have an
hour a day
we invite you know the mayor the city
commissioners and everyone we invite you
know the Christian community the Jewish
community we invite also the atheist
community we invite everyone and
and we asked everyone to come to hear
from us not to hear about us from the
mainstream media which usually demonize
important to learn from us about us not
come to learn from us invite everyone we
extend our hands we open our hands and
our doors and our hearts to everyone
come and learn about the religion of
Islam you will see that the religion of
Islam is the religion of Tolerance the
religion of peace the religion of love
that Islam emphasis on the importance of
importance of generosity the importance
of gentleness the the importance of
tolerance the importance of living in
peace and harmony these are the things
that we teach our children this is
personally what I teach my congregation
that you know one of the objectives of
our creation is to know one another that
God you know created us we have
different you know skin color we have we
belong to different ethnicities a little
out of what we divided you into nations
and tribes so that you may know one
another so we call people to come you
know bring your culture bring your
language doesn't matter how you how you
look what language you speak what
religion you follow come and let us
discuss let us embrace one another so
that now that's how you make America
great again
[Music]
so your your you're what we call a not
yet Muslims often sit because everyone
has this potential to submit to the
creator of the heavens and earth so you
came to visit the Muslims here how's
your experience been and why did you
come hello I'm Daniel I'm from Columbia
I actually manage I get related into
this because most of my friends there
come from like Islamic background and I
always felt lost in the Christianity I
grew up in Catholics Kol just girls
and just Christian school and I just
felt lobster net and I kind of I'm
feeling the harm from our community and
that's why I'm here
how do you how do you feel now that what
how long have you been visiting and is
this your first day or so you've been
coming second day huh how do you like
you know the which would yeah do you
feel at home you feel welcome how is it
in contrast to what you hear in the
media a lot of the hype that's out there
and then versus coming to coming to met
to make the connection with Muslim what
did you say they don't have nothing to
do I don't want to use this word but
terrorism is nothing to do with Muslim
it's actually a great community it's
just about God there is nothing to do
about hurting anyone that's not part of
their religion or followings this is
just bad people you know around the
world and they can be Muslim they can be
Christians they could be a tease they
just could be anyone there's just bad
people around the world oh wow this is
powerful and you're hearing it this was
unplanned I just met what's her name
again this is Daniela
right and so sister Linda before we cut
out there's often this and this is what
the Deen show really focuses on
motivating people to learn to grow to
connect with Muslims clearing the
misconceptions one of those is that when
they see the Muslim woman the one who
has submitted her will to the Creator
that heavens and earth and we say she's
following the example of Mary the mother
of Jesus they see you what's called a
hijab they say she's subjugated she's
oppress what do you say to that when you
hear that you know from my experience
working for the city covering I get more
respect when I was with the city working
for the city one of the officials came
up to me and say you know I think you
are dressed most beautifully why because
the way I dress it makes me respect me
more and it makes the people around me
respect me when they see me they don't
see her jab they see me they're looking
at me because I respect myself and I
never ever will take off my head jab why
because this is who I am
this it makes me who I am you know I'm
63 years old
and I've been wearing my head jab for a
long
time and when you work for city
governments and you work you have 1,000
employees and you're the only one with a
job and people come by you especially
the men and say to you how are you do
you need anything
can I take this package from you can I
open the door for you this shows me that
God Himself Allah the one and only one
I'll tell you is with me why because
against all adversity I'm standing for
Who I am I'm not undressed because I'm
afraid that I won't get a job you know
God gave me the job nobody gave me the
job but my lord so when you fear Allah
and you do what Allah say and you follow
what Allah's words and you obey the
Prophet may peace be upon him who say be
modest cover yourself to protect
yourself and to take care for your
husband not your boyfriend not even your
girlfriend for your husband your modesty
for yourself oh let me tell you
something wearing this a [ __ ] I'm a
superstar when I don't wear my hijab I
feel like I'm nothing
why because I'm not doing it for the
people I'm doing it because I fear my
lord and I'm obeying the greatest man
who ever lived
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
that's deep
you didn't expect all that did you
that's exciting that's deep and she
mentioned she mentioned an Arabic word
for many of people that haven't heard it
but you probably didn't know that Jesus
he called on the crater by Aloha hello
that jesus said on the cross according
to the biblical narrative he says Eloi
Eloi Lema sabachthani you know my god oh
my lord my lord why have you forsaken me
so these are the same terms we mentioned
even before you know we discussed this
together that you know although he in
Eli Levine and Hebrew Allah these this
is you know this is the Aramaic term for
God and then you have the Hebrew term
for God and then you have Allah the
Arabic term and unfortunately this is a
misconception people they say why you
call Allah which is the Lord of the
Muslims and we mentioned this before
that you know you know the quiz
the Arab Christians in the in the in the
Arab Jews also the economy Allah it's
just the Arabic term for God and about
40 million of the Arab Jews and
Christians they call him the economy
Allah in the Arabic Bible which is way
older than the English Bible he is
called Allah so there are many
misconceptions and that's why we have
you know that that one day that's why we
invite people to come to our message so
so to give us the chance to clarify
these misconceptions we tell them you
can come with any question that you have
any question that you have any
misconception come and ask us the
question and we will and we will give
you the proof the textual proof and the
rational proof the textual proof from
the from the ultimate source of Islam
which is the Quran and the in the
traditions of the Prophet and also
rational proof reasonable proof that
would convince you I have no doubt that
I mean that hate I mean that takes a lot
of effort a lot a lot from you I mean
and the only way to rid of it is true to
the correct knowledge and that's the
only way you're gonna grow I mean you
got an invitation for the Muslim I just
want to say this last thing about the
hijab when you look at the history and
the great women of the world who wore
hijab you know we started with our
mother Mary then we started with look at
mother Teresa she was one of the most
beloved women in the world she wore her
jab look at our beloved nuns look at
them
the nuns they all wear he Jack if you
look out through history back from
Western days from you know if you want
to go from Pharaohs world there women
wore hijab they covered we cover a
thousand different ways but we are
covered we are modest what happened to
us
now we don't wear hijab you have more
rapes you have more murders you have so
many bad things happen to women because
we're showing everything we got and
people are taking it from us you find
the Muslim women you know we're modest
and when I look at mother Teresa when I
look at Mary Mother of Jesus may peace
be upon him when I look at all of the
nuns and these famous women who wore had
Jeff they are
the most respected women in history and
that's in the Bible in the Torah in the
Quran you will find these modest women
you get a lot of facts here you're
learning a lot and that's how you're
gonna grow through the proper knowledge
making a connection because I'm telling
you it takes a lot more energy harboring
that hate and you only shackle yourself
and hold yourself back but look you've
already learned a few things and that
light bulb went on aha
they had aha moment even lied to a lot
of the times people are out there trying
to polarize separate us but we just gave
an invitation to the Trump come and
visit to the Trump followers any final
words any final under yes president
United States again we extend our
invitation in Daytona Beach Florida
mustard it's right down the street from
your beautiful home right down the road
he's down the road he's right down the
road so you get on the highway the byway
or we will come and get you ourselves we
want to bring you to our mosh did so you
can spend the day or a few hours to get
to know the whole mosque because when
you come to Daytona Beach you believe me
you will find the whole world here and
why I say that you find Muslim from
Yemen you find Muslim from Africa you
find Muslim from China you find Muslim
from Russia and they don't have anything
in common except Allah Allah they say
the same thing and one thing that we all
say the same language we may speak
different but one language is the same i
Salam or Nicholas that's how we agreed
to one another how this is how we greet
our guests peace be upon you and it's
not just words that we utter we mean it
we mean what we say and we say what we
mean when we say Salaam alaikum peace be
upon you this is a covenant this is a
treaty between us and you that means we
will never harm you we will never hurt
you we will show you love we will show
you compassion and you know even when
you take the the Koran which is the the
holy book of them so the ultimate source
of the Muslims if you open the the Quran
the first surah which is solitude Fatiha
the opening of the Quran God introduces
himself to the humanity as a romaine
miss Miller rahmanir rahim' in the name
of allah the most
beneficient in the most merciful and
then he says hamd inaudible al-amin the
Lord of the entire humanity this is this
is our message it's a universal message
it's for everyone and we say that and
the Prophet peace be upon him II said
about the Quran this is the banquet of
Allah and you're invited to us so we
invite everyone we invite Donald Trump
we invite each and every person to come
and to enjoy the banquet of Allah which
is the hold on and you will find the
Muslim community we do practice the best
manners
so when you come here you will find us
waiting for you with the best food the
best manners so mr. Trump please come
and visit the Muslim say what you mean
and mean what you say and see see the
unity the prior one of the objectives of
the of the prayer is unity and you will
see that people you know from Africa
sister Linda mentioned from Africa from
Asia
you know from Mexico from all over the
world they are they are they are
standing next to each other foot to foot
and shoulder to shoulder you know
there's they are praying to one God
towards one direction it was the same
direction and they are doing the same
rights the same rituals and in the
prayer this I think shows unity that the
Muslim community is the United community
we have differences we have difference
of opinions we have we have memory you
know many differences amongst ourselves
but we have one thing in common which is
you know the love that we have for this
country the love that we have for the
entire humanity and the thing that bond
us together which is a bond greater than
the bond of blood and lineage which is
Allah there is no deity worthy of
worship except God and that we strongly
believe that Jesus preached Abraham Noah
all of them they preached that there is
no deity worthy of worship except God
and Jesus at the first command you know
Schama Israel which is behold o children
of Israel
my Lord and your Lord is one in the same
thing that he says in Surat Maryam that
my Lord and your Lord is one so this is
the message of all the prophets and
messengers it is a message of monotheism
it's also a message of unity a message
of harmony and a message of love to add
to that father you know God said if he
wanted to make us one you know one
maimie he would I would be right but
well he made us different but one thing
that also in adding what the Imam said
you know we all are different but we all
breathe the same air we all eat what the
same way we all see the same way so
we're different but yet we are the same
we're our Father Adam our mother Eve we
all walk under two feet even though some
of us I think welcomed the top of my
head you know but the bottom line is we
are still one commendeth the best of you
according to the Quran is not the person
who's you know the most wealthiest or
the most famous he said in a Croma
Chaminda lieth become the most noble of
you and the sight of God is the most
righteous regardless of your skin color
your nationality your ethnicity
this is the message of the Quran the
Prophet peace be upon him said in a lot
and or in a supportive community exam
does not look at your facial appearance
it does not look at your bodies are your
clothes you look at your heart and your
actions we know that we know that Donald
Trump he has a good heart and we Muslim
we want to show him that we too have a
good heart and we want him to to see him
we want to let him know that we are very
merciful - even the ant that crawls on
the ground even the bird and the plants
even the even the plants even the trees
we want him to know our community so
when he goes before the world he will
have a better understanding of the
entire Muslim community around the world
yeah yeah so so we've covered a lot of
ground you even I mean she mentioned all
these nationalities we even got a
Bosnian American here Salam alaikum
Salam yes so you got all of us here and
you often heard this before we cut out
Trump he has said some probably that we
can clear that up he said
I think Islam hates us I think Islam
hates us have you heard that that
statement before yeah I heard you've
heard that before so we but I think it's
the opposite it's quite the opposite
Islam loves you Islam once that which is
good for you as you know as an
individual and also as as a country and
as a community
Islam Islam cause people to be merciful
Islam cause people to be generous Aslam
calls people to be patient Islam calls
people not to harm in in killing one
innocent human being is like killing the
entire humanity Islam does not hate you
Islam calls you to that which is good so
then calls you to have good characters
Islam Islam Islam tells you to stay away
you know and and to stay away from that
which is evil from that which is bad
Aslam tells you not to harm a human
being
Aslam tells you that even if you lock up
a cat and you did and you do not feed
that cat and it dies that you will go
into the Hellfire Aslam tells us and
tells everyone that a woman a prostitute
from the previous generations she gave
water to a dog interesting in God and
she was merciful to a dying in God I
gave her Jinnah that's the word of God
for a person a prostitute who gave water
to a die
Aslam tells you even to respect the
environment and an Islam tells you to
respect the parents Islam tells you to
respect your siblings Islam tells you
that the best thing that you do after
believing in God is to be respectful and
dutiful to your parents Islam gives you
the answers Aslam tells you that if you
are a good person if you believe in God
you become a good person then you will
live in paradise forever eternal life it
will be your abode forever this is what
Islam loves you Islam gives you hope
Islam gives you hope Islam tells you
that there is no differences
between a white person and a black
person Aslam tells you that everyone are
equal and we are equal on the sight of
God this is a Salam so Islam promotes
love it does not promote hatred hate and
SM does not promote war it's not
promotes peace even Jesus he said God
made me dutiful to my mother to my
mother you know Mary his mother you see
we didn't even want to scratch the
surface I mean a week that's a whole
different topic about you know an
article of faith being it to believe in
love Jesus is one of the mightiest
messengers you cannot be a Muslim and
telling unless you believe in Jesus
Christ based upon if you say I'm a
Muslim but you know I have a problem
with Jesus I don't believe in him then
you're not a Muslim no matter what you
do no even if you come to the mosque you
know I'm on a daily basis you know if
you spent your life in the mosque if you
don't believe in Jesus and you believe
that he's a prophet and you follow and
you follow him and you follow his
message and you follow his way and you
follow his path and you respect his
mother would we have an entire chapter
on called the chapter of Mary she is not
only woman that is mentioned by name in
the Quran the wife of the Prophet does
not mentioned the daughter of the
Prophet is not mentioned by name but
Miriam she has an entire chapter that
describes how how chaste and how
honorable woman she was yeah and you're
imitating you become a superstar because
you're emulating Mary the mother of
Jesus one of the mightiest messengers
ever sent with who came to the same
exact message and all the other prophets
and the last and final messenger prophet
mohammed peace and wisdom calling people
to worship the Creator not the creation
one more thing that came to mind you
have some people out there unfortunately
don't they say you know what how that
all sounds good it's a lot of fluff you
know these people are using takea you
heard this word what would you say today
well the term tapia is used
I mean is it is true that this in
nowhere in the Quran is soon this has
nothing this is this even this term the
answers for example if someone is
forcing you someone is threatening your
life to say something in Islam it is
okay to say it it is okay for example
like in the case of Mr benét Azhar one
of the close companions of the Prophet
peace be upon him when he was tortured
and both his parents were killed and
then they told him if you do not say
something negative about Islam we will
kill you
so he said something negative about
Islam so the Prophet came to him and he
was crying he said I apologize to the
properties that I did not mean to but
they tortured me and they abused me
verbally and physically and they
threatened my life so the Prophet said
if they wash you again to say something
negative about me and Islam say it
because you are afraid for your life but
we're not afraid for our lives there's
nothing there's not no one is forcing us
to say anything this is a Salam
this is Aslam we're open book you have
the Koran and you have this one of the
promise on him and we tell people
because some of them they say you know
one person he told me one time he said
you know when you come to the church
maybe you're saying good things or when
you invite us to your mosque you're
saying you know good things positive
things but and you're you know he said
in your special classes and your sermons
maybe you say something I said you are
welcome one time I'll give you the term
of Jota and come at you know you come
anytime and if you feel that there is
something that is we are you know
spreading hate or we're talking about
you know we are for example emphasizing
on on killing or hatred all that then
you can come to me and say yes they
probably I mean nowadays I mean they
probably have all the other all the
mosques bugged already so they're
probably listening to there's nothing to
hide exactly one thing an often example
that I make is that it just like it
during this thing because this is a way
to like shut people's ears to get them
away from hearing the truth and the
haters they'll probably be a lot of
times push this out this thing and is
that imagine when the Nazis were coming
knocking on doors looking for Jews right
and they wanted to kill them you had in
that case but say you were hiding a
family right you were hiding children in
the basement whatever you had Islam
gives you a right to protect these
people now you're able to say if they
came said where where are these kids
where are they they're trying to get the
Jews you you could say because Tecna
you're lying you say no they're not here
right so this would be a form but
technically there is no
from my investigation no there is no
word that we use called takea no this is
something I believe from the the Shiite
is not part of the Shia theology which
is even in the time of war or even in
the time of peace they are allowed
unfortunately to lie and to tell you you
know things that are different from what
they believe you know the opposite of
what they believe but in Islam and we're
talking about the 96% of Muslims because
this is the Sunnah they make up about
996 or 95% of the Muslims this is maybe
something that people even don't know do
you think that one decision and Shia
they think 50% arson and 50% are Shia
and we have denominations just like the
Christians know the the mainstream Islam
which is the mainstream Muslim we're
talking about sooner they make up 95 or
96 percent of the Muslim population so
what we believe is that you have to
stand up for that which is happy for the
truth you have to speak your mind you
have to express your opinion freely you
have to tell people what you believe
this is Dawa you can't lie to me because
I know we believe in two gods or we're
you know we're we lie to people there is
no gain there is no benefit in this
country in this country you are
protected we have freedom of speech you
can say whatever you want to say if we
live in a different country and and if
you if you speak your mind then you you
will get killed and that's a different
case then we say maybe these Muslims are
lying in their music as you mentioned or
Tokyo but there's nothing everybody
saying you can say whatever you want to
say we could have covered a lot in the
last point no such thing as dakea in
Islam it's long calls you to be truthful
and ultimate truth is the call to
worship the Creator not the creation and
we covered the myth and the
misconception you got to speak to our
sister Linda here the superstar who's
following the example of Mary the mother
of Jesus the love that we have for Jesus
and the event again for Trump to come in
you got invitation to the President to
come to connect with the Muslims and
anyone else that's in April that's here
information who to contact imam bailout
year you should contact us and then
we'll give them them yes people can do
that um i can give you my number they
can make date they'll find they'll find
you easy if they want yeah you will find
me and imam Bulow here in charlotte with
the rest of my here and you'll find out
he'll invited all sorts of our houses
you can bring his family also with them
yes yes he's right down the road here in
florida thank you guys thank you guys
thank you for tuning in and here thank
you for your efforts and me i love us
you and me a lovely beautiful father and
your family does welcome to Daytona
Beach and again your father looks like
your brother so you know where to find
us every week here at the Dean show
subscribe if you haven't already we'll
see you next time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be with you Salaam alaikum